-Performing "Handle on You"
from his upcoming album,
"Never Enough," give it up
for Parker McCollum!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I went and bought
the biggest bottle they got ♪
♪ 'Cause you're gone ♪
♪♪
♪ Drop the needle on a vinyl ♪
♪ And cry
to an old Haggard song ♪
♪♪
♪ Sittin' at the table, baby,
breaking the seal ♪
♪ Gonna see how much
of this pain I can kill ♪
♪ I went and bought
the biggest bottle they got ♪
♪ 'Cause you're gone ♪
♪♪
♪ Tennessee and Kentucky ♪
♪ 'Cause you ain't here
to love me ♪
♪ I drink now that
there's nothing to lose ♪
♪ I've been fightin'
with your memory ♪
♪ I hate the way it hits me ♪
♪ I wake up every day
black and blue ♪
♪ After all this back-and-forth,
a fifth won't do ♪
♪♪
♪ Yeah, I finally got a handle ♪
♪ Finally got a handle on you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ I tell myself
that I should quit ♪
♪ But I don't listen to drunks ♪
♪♪
♪ So I keep on sipping till ♪
♪ "I miss you"
don't roll off my tongue ♪
♪♪
♪ Since you poured our love
down the sink ♪
♪ I think I'll just
stay here and drink ♪
♪ I tell myself
that I should quit ♪
♪ But I don't listen to drunks ♪
♪♪
♪ Tennessee and Kentucky ♪
♪ 'Cause you ain't here
to love me ♪
♪ I drink now that
there's nothing to lose ♪
♪ I've been fightin'
with your memory ♪
♪ I hate the way it hits me ♪
♪ I wake up every day
black and blue ♪
♪ After all this back-and-forth,
a fifth won't do ♪
♪ Well, I finally
got a handle on you ♪
♪♪
♪ After all this back-and-forth,
a fifth won't do ♪
♪♪
♪ Yeah, I finally got a handle ♪
♪ Finally got a handle on you ♪
♪ Whoo-ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Handle on you ♪
♪ Yeah, I finally
got a handle on you ♪
♪ Whoo-ooh-ooh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]